die goodgame game hallo ich meine lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen zu einer
runden zieht wo ich doch mal über meine
zeit bei war o2 rede
jahrhundert angefangen und ich war
eigentlich ein neuer blog aber irgendwie
sind ganz viele reiter direkt am anfang
gestorben als im boden gespannt sind
oder so keine ahnung was hier mit halb
immer wieder los ist jedenfalls bin ich
jetzt ein super und ich spiele außerdem
auch mit einem sex weihnachts jedenfalls
dachte ich mir das ist doch eigentlich
ganz ehrlich oder in diesem blog diesem
blog blog das eigentlich wenn ich so
einen weihnachts special pack ab und
eventuell ins boot kommen morgen auch
eine serie die ein wenig weihnachtlich
angehauchte das wie so was wie sterben
gestellt dieser cup blog wieso steht er
denn nicht wenn ich sinnlos mit dem wie
oft musste er noch treffen
endlich so total und zwar ich weiß auch
gar nicht was sie denn das hier in das
kisten ich muss mich erst noch anschauen
was hier alles diese ganzen blöcke hier
sind jedenfalls wollte ich über meine
truppe war o2 reden man tief dass das
das ruckelt hier wie so guckt euch das
mal an der block bett legen wir auf
einmal stehen und dann ist ja wieder
fünf blöcke weiter hier weil ich sinnlos
mit diesem kennt mich freunde ich kann
kaum beim thema bleiben wenn ich
nebenbei gegen verspiele was ist denn
das da bleibt der lok steht man denkt
man kann ihn boxen und dann hüpft er
etwa wieder weiter oder das ist einfach
sein
das ist ein internet dass das liegt
nicht am server das ist ein internet
dass er immer irgendwie hängen bleibt
evivi kacke ist das denn
kommen jetzt kriegt ihn jetzt weg
abschneiden bei
ab 2017 soll das wahrscheinlich nicht
sehr viel ich laufe jetzt mal einfach
geschält hier so ein bisschen rum dann
bin ich jetzt endlich über das reden
kann aber was ich reden möchte ich
glaube das sind blumentöpfe oder er das
in blumentöpfe und zwar wie ihr alle
wisst bin ich ja bei war o2 in der
ersten folge gestorben ich wollte es
jetzt nochmal alles hier so ein bisschen
zusammen fassen weil viele mich auch
gefragt hatten jan luca nicht voll
traurig und du hast du tot bist du oder
das relativ egal und ich mache aber ein
video darüber und zwar
muss ich echt sagen es ist klar scheint
der grat auf dem schild es ist eine
sache die ich noch nicht ganz begreifen
kann dass ich in dieser ersten folge
gestorben bin und zwar am käfer nicht
diese taktik gedacht wegen dahin wir
gehen dahin ich mache die schwerter ich
mache dies ich mach das heft macht die
skype macht da sondern treffen uns
gleich und angehende höhe und es hat
alles super geklappt und ich habe mir
dann auch nochmal gomez und weiß folge
angeschaut weil ihr mich ja getötet und
kev und das war halt wirklich mehreren
zufall dass wir unseren namen gesehen
haben und das war so ein bisschen ein
bisschen traurig dass du dann direkt den
ersten folge gestorben sind
die bombe ist jetzt alleine im team und
es kam auch viele kommentare so anja es
soll so sein dass in der ersten folge
darf man niemanden töten und so ist es
auch eigentlich ich weiß nicht ich hätte
gute oder schlechte seiten wenn sie eine
ersten folge so wer aber ich glaube
gerade wenn man diese regel einführen
würde dass man in der ersten folge
niemanden töten davon dass das ganze
erst nach und nach passiert dann wäre
der ganze charakter irgendwie weg gerade
das tolle an war es einfach dass man
immer und überall gefährdet ist
irgendwas irgendwie angegriffen zu
werden und ich weiß nicht ob ihr schon
das video
ich will jetzt nichts beulen oder so
weil ich nicht weiß wann ich das hier
raus bringen aber ich denke es wird
schon ein video online sein wo wieder
teilnehmer in faro sterben und ich denke
auch ehrlich dass dieses projekt diesmal
nicht so lange dauern wird und das war
ja extra das absicht war mit der mit der
regel
regel geben mit diesen ganzen neuen
regeln dass man beispielsweise dass
dieses blut raus oder sowas schon oft
angesprochen wurde in videos dass man
wirklich einer bestimmten zeit dazu
verpflichtet ist sich anzugreifen und
andere leute einfach zu boxen das heißt
in spätestens in ein paar folgen die das
emea ab wie so ruckelt das denn jetzt
hier alles sich das an diesem punkt
elften gp patrick speck oder das ist für
16 64
was ist los jedenfalls dass gerade diese
regeln sind das ganze was war ganz
interessant macht und zwar damals beim
mega projekt war es halt so man hatte
gar keine regeln mehr oder weniger also
es gab halt nicht wenig reger kuppen und
beten ist also es gab halt damals bei
mega projekt echt wenig regeln muss ich
sagen und es war halt trotzdem witziges
projekt aber das war einfach das erste
was man so groß als community gemacht
hat es gibt einfach nur noch ein haider
ich denke ich bin behindert und findet
einfach kein aber der scheint wohl echt
gut versteckt zu sein und es gibt halt
auch einfach nur noch ein megaprojekt
was halt so dass es keine regeln gab und
das ganze halt nur die daher interessant
war es das erste mal war dass wir alle
zusammen ein großes projekt hatten und
bei war ofin ist jetzt halt
dementsprechend ganz geil bauabschnitten
gefunden aber nee hab ich nicht the
following haltet have the best agers
richmond 13 kills hat eine alte idee
game game ich bin jetzt in der nächsten
lobby also ich weiß nicht ich finde dass
gerade ganz geil dass beim war o2 jetzt
so viele regeln am start waren und ich
respektiere das ja auch total dass ich
getötet wurde also ich habe jetzt nicht
irgendwie umgehängt oder bader extrem
traurig natürlich traurig aber ich habe
jetzt nicht gewillt den regel das direkt
tot bin oder so weil ich finde
eigentlich als interessant und ich finde
immer besser wenn etwas passiert hallo
bunter man immer besser wenn etwas
passiert als wenn einfach die ganze zeit
nichts passiert so wie in war u2 vivaro
1 2 kickers und mir deswegen
es war halt traurig dass wir gestorben
sind aber ich denke jetzt nicht dass das
ein großer verlust ist ich meine schaut
einfach bei den anderen teams vorbei und
es ist ja auch vielleicht ganz cool pics
blog welche nehme ich da nicht nehmen
ich nehme gelbes geschenke geldgeschenk
minecraft hey blog ok blog ist ein
gelbes geschenk das ist ein crafting
tempo aber sonst ist hier nichts
weihnachtlicher ist es ist diesmal auch
bei sex gar nicht so viel weihnachtlich
finde ich ich weiß gar nicht wie das mit
denen mit denen mit der mitte jetzt wir
sind auch schon wieder alle im boden
gespannt was ist schwachsinn der wahl
guckt mal die erde ist wirklich wieder
so schnell haltig gehalten schnee halte
weiß gar nicht wo kann ich denn hin hier
sind wahrscheinlich wieder die meisten
wieder an
ich hab das geschenk auf den kopf ja
hallo ich schicke die tür nicht auf
wieso okay dann gehe ich woanders ein
ich weiß echt nicht wo ich mich
verstecken soll alter ich habe gerade
überhaupt keinen plan oder vorne wird
auch schon jemand verfolgt
die können ja auch die treppe hoch auch
duca clarke duca kommen nicht hinterher
kommen wir nicht daher kommen
ich verstehe mich jetzt hier mit keiner
ich werde und ich werde
invisible comcom okay jetzt wenig
versteckt und zwar ich weiß nicht also
ich finds eigentlich echt ganz cool
vivaro zwei bisher verläuft und auch
nicht sicher da auch hinter den kulissen
so ein bisschen noch was mit
trotz netzen nicht raus bin aber ich
denke es wird ganz cool die nächsten
folgen bei einigen teilnehmern und ich
denke jetzt wird auch noch ein richtig
spannendes projekt also ich bin jetzt
nicht jemand der sagt wie kacke dass ich
da raus bin natürlich habe ich mich auf
pharo gefreut weil war ohne ein projekt
gewesen wäre ihr wisst es main kanal der
zeit und das sagen auch einige dass es
eventuell nicht so cool ist
viele sagen halt dass dies nicht so cool
finden das main kanal so ein bisschen
aus videos besteht die er so fünf bis
zehn minuten lang sein und geschnitten
sind nur beim nächsten halt derzeit so
dass ich
2 ich finds halt also ich legte selber
für mich fest ich finde es besser ein
video am tag zu machen was gut
bearbeitet ist wo man sieht er steckt
liebe zum detail drin als wenn ich zwei
videos mache die einfach dahin
geschissen sind und irgendwie 20 minuten
lang und mit ganz viel und pausen und
alles möglich ich meine das video hier
wird ja als auch wieder bearbeitet seien
zwar nicht so viel aber auf jeden fall
ein bisschen zusammen geschnitten damit
nicht so was wir da drin vorkommt
allerdings haben dass auch viele
bemängelt und zwar meinten diakonie wir
wollen mal wieder von diesem projekt
sehen wo du wirklich so einfach last und
nicht so viel bearbeitet und einfach so
ein einzelspieler projekt nicht immer
dieses also die leute meinten halt ist
soll so ein projekt geben
technisat bunte mensch gemeint ich soll
mal wieder so ein projekt geben wo ich
einfach selber spiele und wo die wissen
da kommt jeden tag eine folge von
einfach sowas fortlaufendes war derzeit
ist es so jeden tag kommt auf einem
kanal was anderes man kann nie wissen
was kommt heute manier wusste zum
beispiel auch nicht dass jetzt heute
irgendwie noch dieses vario video kommt
neben der mod vorstellung oder so dirr
wirst doch nicht was morgen auf einem
kanal kommt es gibt quasi nur diese
minecraft weg sie mal dienstags und
freitags kommen wo man weiß ob die
dienstags und freitags qantas und andere
kanäle da ist es halt so ok montag
dienstag mittwoch donnerstag samstag
sonntag kommt jeden tag 38 dieses video
bin ich halt eigentlich nicht so der fan
von allerdings haben dass sie sich
wirklich viele gewünscht ich mir gedacht
ich mach das mal wieder und deswegen
habe ich mir überlegt dass ich einfach
mit war o2 dieses projekt dann quasi
habe das jeden tag war u2 com bis wir
sterben irgendwie so vorgenommen unter
die top ten besten teams also top 20
irgendwie also dass wir dann irgendwie
weiß ich nicht so 20 30h überleben in
sarow da hätte ich auf jeden fall schon
mal so ein projekt was jeden tag
fortlaufend kommt aber jetzt bin ich
halt tod und deswegen geht das ganze
jetzt nicht allerdings ist ja wenn ihr
das video seht gerade der dreißigste
elfte und wenn man hier mal so rum zählt
so auf diesem blog ist ja eigentlich
irgendwo ein blog oder warum gehen die
alle so weiß man ja dass morgen der
erste dezember ist und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht
letzten jahre kamen ja mal so ist kraft
vielleicht kommt das ja wieder ich weiß
ja nicht vielleicht fängt das morgen an
mal schauen mal schauen und dann hat man
eventuell ein 24 projekt was man da dann
hochladen kann euch weiß nicht
vielleicht kommt da was vielleicht kommt
auch nichts eine ahnung wenn ihre ideen
habt ihr übrigens so was faul zu was
kommen sollte wie ich das eventuell
besser gestalten könnte dann könnt ihr
mir das auch bitte einfach in die
kommentare schreiben
dieser weltstadt der verhindert das ist
aber nicht der typ mit diesem komischen
bunten anzug oder ein richtig gutes im
schilde einfach rum und lagern bis hin
aber na ja bei mir ruckelt das auch
irgendwie extrem auf diesem server ich
weiß nicht woran liegt das
woran liegt das konkrete bleibt stehen
gerade wenn mir jemand sowas schreibt
konkreter bleibt stehen so könntest du
vielleicht stehen beim oder können wir
vielleicht ein foto machen dann in
ordnung aber einfach so konkret bestimmt
nur durch könig und logue weg vor ihm
wir haben verloren oder gewonnen keine
ahnung ist mir egal
dieser kroko button nein nein lass mich
in ruhe ich hoffe euch hat das gefallen
ich weiß nicht ob ich meine ganze
meinung so ein bisschen näher bringen
konnte euch aber es ist halt so ich bin
nicht wirklich also natürlich nimmt es
mich nicht so krass mit dass jetzt
gestorben bin wie das eventuell bei
einigen anderen der fall ist oder so
aber es ist bei mir halt so ich hätte
wirklich mit war o2 sein projekt gehabt
wo ich endlich mal wieder wirklich so
ein projekt gehabt hätte was jetzt aber
doch nicht am start ist allerdings ist
der ssd zimmer das heißt eventuell
startet christmas kraft mal wieder in
eine neue runde ich weiß nicht wieso
nennen werde ich muss mir überlegen was
das land jetzt aufnehmen allerdings tut
mir einfach leid das war wo zwei jetzt
direkt nach einer folge vorbei ist ich
hab mir dann so gedacht als
entschädigung bearbeitet das video ganz
witzig wenn es noch nicht gesehen habt
dann schaut euch an das ist auf meinem
kanal dann würde ich sagen freue ich
mich über jede bewertung von euch die
ihr dallas weil das mir mal zeigt dass
es euch gefällt was ich hier mache wenn
wir 5000 like schaffen passiert einfach
gar nichts so wie der stürmer will das
auch mal sagt aber es wird mich auf
jeden fall freuen und
ich sage einfach mal dann ich wünsche
euch noch einen wunderschönen
sonntagabend und dann sehen wir uns in
einem nächsten video wieder deuce